welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down Five Nights at
Freddy's the brand new movie based off
the original video game has just dropped
and throughout this video we're going to
be going through it all Straight Out The
Gate heavy spoilers ahead so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out
then please check out now also hit the
Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy the video
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into Five Nights at
Freddy's okay the movie Loosely adapts
the game whilst adding in some human
drama to help P things out who it's one
of those now in it we follow Michael
Schmidt Who's down on his luck after
losing his job as a m cop due to him
assaulting a man that he thought had
kidnapped a child we learned that Mike's
brother Garrett was kidnapped when he
was younger and Mike's being haunted by
Nightmares of the event every night
studying dream theories we can see this
book by his bedside and it somewhat
plays in the visions that he has later
on being offered a security job by
counselor Steve Raglin he shows up to
Freddy's reluctant to get to work times
is hard mate and I got to work in the
ghost murderous arcade to get money to
help buy Funko Pops no now the thing
that makes Michael take the job is that
he's trying to retain custody of his
younger sister Abby and th he needs to
keep it so she isn't shipped off to an
Jane oh God not an Jane now as you'd
probably expect the job isn't all this
cracked up to be and things get stranger
and stranger the longer the nights go on
falling asleep on the side he begins the
recurring nightmares of seeing his
brother's kidnap however something
changes when he's at Freddy's he starts
to dream of five children which have to
be careful how I wor that would you ever
see there and get comfortable from that
I feel this going you had a feeling what
was going to happen however it turns out
these are the specters of five kids that
disappeared in the restaurant their
bodies were never found and though
Freddy's was closed down the owners said
to be sentiment mental so he's kept the
site running now these kids all share
certain looks that play of the
animatronics in the restaurant which
becomes important later on the film
Michael starts to learn more about them
through a police officer named Vanessa
and through the dreams themselves now
while all this is going on and Jane
hires some shady characters including
aby's babysitter to get Mike fired Jane
had the babysitter actually going
through Mike's to see if there was
anything they could use to incriminate
him with and this is why she didn't mind
not getting paid very ever now while
this is going on they're served by a
waiter who you might recognize as being
YouTuber Matt Pat Matt Pats dive deep
into the five nights law and he's
dropped a number of Theory videos on the
series over the years man even gets to
drop a little reference to this as when
he's serving them he says some people
say that but you know it's just a theory
are you being paid by the word or could
we have a minute one day I'll get a role
in a movie myself and I promise you guys
I'll say the also shout outs to editor
mat for pointing out that him talking
about about food and theories might be a
deep cut reference to his food Theory
Channel he also pointed out at the 28
minute Mark that we might also get a
deep cut to sans's Nest super cool if
that's the case Matt obsesses over this
stuff even more than I do and he always
spots these things H so yeah shout outs
to him and bloody good job as always as
the group descend on the restaurant are
of course attacked by the animatronics
leading to a blood bath their corpses
are stuffed inside the spare suits which
foreshadows are reveal with the kit
throughout the film you also get little
nods to games including Easter eggs that
call back to the source material at one
point we see a damaged dog and I kind of
took this as being an to Sparky there's
also Mar with it's me and a couple of
things that we'll talk about later now
due to her babysitter getting smashed
like the like button Steve hasn't got
anyone to look after Abby th she comes
with them to the restaurant which is
when the animatronics start up again
unlike the night before though they're
friendly to Abby which is when we learn
about the souls of the kids possessing
the machines talking about the yellow
rabbit constantly we also see how this
is similar to what happened with Garrett
Now Vanessa warns Mike not bring Abby
back and in the end Mike turns to Jane
for help going back to the restaurant he
Chucks back sleeping pills and this is
in order to get to the bottom of who
kidnapped his brother coming across the
kids they offer Steve the chance to live
with Gare forever and all he has to do
is hand over Abby now while this is
going on Freddy Fazbear appears at
Jane's house and murders her before then
taking Abby in his dreams the kids go
Freddy Krueger and start attacking him
which is when he wakes up strapped to a
tortured device managing to escape he's
then helped by Vanessa which is when we
get one of the first major reveals turns
out Vanessa is the daughter of the
serial killer William Aton who killed
the kids and put their bodies in the
animatronics this is why they were never
found and their souls are now under his
control and in the end we learn Williams
actually posing as Steve yet Matthew
Lillard he's the killer once more and
there's actually some Clues to this lace
throughout the intro those 8bit Graphics
have his name appear on screen at a key
time and we also see as his character
leads away the kids it was all that in
the intro which leads to this opening
actually being great to rewatch after
you've seen the film now William in the
end dresses up in the spring bunny suit
and goes on the attack at one point he
actually wipes blood off his knife which
is a direct reference to Lillard's movie
Scream in that he of course played ghost
face and also wipe the blood like this
when going against Cindy now though
Vanessa had worked with him in the past
she ends up shooting father however she
gets stabs and it puts the character at
de's door this somewhat helps to redeem
herself though as she was a child when
Garett got taken in the end Abby ends up
drawing a picture of what William really
did and this turns all the kids against
him setting off the spring lock
Machinery inside his suit the guy's
taken out once and for all or is he now
Mike and Abby lead Vanessa at the
restaurant but at this point she falls
into a coma though we don't get any
resolution to this I'm guessing that
we'll see her popping up if we ever get
a sequel
so far the movie is getting really bad
reviews but if it makes bank then I'm
sure the studios won't care also I don't
know why the police wouldn't check out
the animatronics to see where the bodies
are But Here we are now great work
Vanessa for working as a policewoman and
covering up the murder case and you
better bloody hope you don't wake out
that coma in the end we close out to
Spring bunny starting up and as he says
he always comes back now this of course
seases things to come and I'm guessing
that Vanessa will be back to help stop
her dad again there's also the fact that
she has crucial knowledge of Freddy's
and can help deal with what's really
going on there who knows she might even
inherit it and could be the person that
keeps the evil trapped inside wait is
that is that Beck I just realized that's
Beck from you not you now as for Mike I
think him giving up Abby actually helps
to change the arc that he goes on Mike
was someone who felt guilt over what
happened to his brother and it's clear
that he blamed himself for his
disappearance the spirits used this to
manipulate him with Abby and he gave her
up as a way to help Soo the pain he felt
in the end though he snapped out of this
and put the focus back on Abby so he
could be there for an way that he hadn't
been before the whole movie is basically
about whether he's good enough to take
care of her as a brother because he
didn't feel like he could after what
happened with Garrett however after all
he's been through we know that he is
which brings things full circle from the
beginning now the PIR maker packed to
visit the restaurant again to see her
friends hinting at the horror not ending
now on top of the tease we also have a
mid-credit scene that could be hinting
at where things might be heading and it
weer to Taxi Driver that's popped up in
the film and he's played by none other
than Cory Kenshin in case you don't know
he's also a YouTuber that did
playthroughs of the game on his channel
this helped build up the popularity of
it and it's clear the creative team feel
like they're indebted to him in some way
there were actually plans to have
Markiplier in it too but unfortunately
his schedule didn't line up he uploaded
his first let's play back in 2014 and
it's got over 114 million views helping
the Game grow on popularity it's a shame
that he never got to be here but
hopefully they find a way to include him
in the future aord scared by balloon boy
who's popped up to startle mic
throughout the film first appearing in
the second game it's possible that he
hints to where things are going actually
think that they might have him team up
with William and even introduce some of
the characters that we missed out here
this could usher in the appearance of
someone like circus baby and bring in
some more villains if we ever get that
sequel at roughly they minimark we get
somewhat of a hint towards her and
though I might not be it might not be
here we could see a pop a again now
that's a big if as we still don't know
how the movies performed and things seem
to be mixed amongst the fan Community I
know some love it and some have had
their problems but either way I think
it'll be a big hit over Halloween
dropping this in cinemas and on peacock
day one probably shows the studio aren't
to fixated on the money as the movie
only costs 20 million to make I can easy
see it getting this back and then it'll
probably Branch out from there to create
future films movies made for streaming
they tend to be done without a full
focus on profit and this definitely
seems like it's going to have an
audience as for my thoughts on it I felt
a bit disappointed and a lot like the
lawyer just sat there
like they kind of create a plot that
tries to carry the film when all we
really want is to just see the killing I
think the big struggle with it is that
the movie doesn't really know what it
wants to be and there's so many tonal
changes throughout that unfortunately
keep it unbalanced you have a depressive
introspective look at the brother of a
child that was kidnapped and then stuff
that's played out like we're part of a
comedy I feel like Wily's Wonderland was
way better balanced tonally and in my
opinion it was a better five nights film
than what this movie was whenever they
Lean Into The Source material out this
film really SES but when it's doing its
own thing I I feel like it struggles in
the end I think it's an okay time if you
go on with your brain turned off and
just sit back and enjoy the little nods
and moments that we get with the
animatronics the movie won't be for a
lot of people but I think fans will like
it though I think the most hardcore ones
even those might see it as slightly
falling short I think when you release
something at Halloween you're kind of
throwing yourself out against other
Halloween movies and This falls short in
comparison to hundreds of other films in
the end I'm giving it a five out of 10
but if you disagree then let me know
Below in general I'd also love to hear
your thoughts and also if there's any
Easter eggs that we didn't catch in our
watch through please drop a like and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button we get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to help us sad you
want to get some heavy spoilers merch
we've also got our t-shirt line located
below the video that will let you pick
up all kinds of tops like our Theory
time one house of dragon stuff Marvel
teas and a lot more we drop new designs
on there all the time too so definitely
keep an eye out for them have you want
some else to watch you've got a video on
screen right now so definitely head over
there right after this by the way huge
thank you for sing through the video
I've been Paul I'll see you next time
take care
peace